i'm just going to do one like circle
yeah yeah whoa
hit a lap head oh my lordy all right
come on let's go let's get it
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by john bernthal he's
an actor you know from films like fury
and ford vs ferrari to mega hit tv shows
like the punisher and the walking dead
as well as award-winning plays like
small engine repair which he now stars
and again as a film adaptation you can
also catch him in the much buzzed about
king richard which tells the story of
tennis superstars venus and serena
williams and their father coach richard
williams set to release on november 19th
john bernthal you've been a very busy
guy thanks for taking the time for hot
ones and welcome to the show thank you
man i i really appreciate you having me
man i'm i'm excited to be here before we
dig in how are you around the spicy
stuff but you know it is not my bag man
it is not i'm i'm be completely honest
uh so uh i'm a little bit nervous uh i i
come with uh reverence respect and uh
humility but i am i'm intent on on on
conquering today i hope i don't have to
swallow those words but i will swallow
these wings
[Music]
that's delicious yeah man
i saw matt damon eat like the whole win
i have a lot of respect for that i'm not
gonna spike it like he did
but
very good
[Music]
whoa
that's good
[Music]
all right
whoa
holy [ __ ]
give me just this take your time man
yeah
that was new yeah yeah i'm good
yeah yeah one sec
just caught like a on the windpipe
all right i'm back yes sir
so one of the many highly anticipated
projects you have on the way is king
richard which recently premiered a
telluride and in it you play williams
sister's tennis coach rick macy and as
an athlete i know it incenses you when
movies feature actors who've clearly
never thrown a ball before what was your
preparation like for this film in order
to avoid similar admonishment from
tennis fans yeah it's the same way as if
you're training with weapons or with
like you have to have that stuff on
point and yeah man like being being a
baseball player i played football as a
boxer you know when you see those things
not working you've got to make it so the
experts look and they say okay they did
their job i buy that that's what you're
going for so
you know i trained i got really lucky in
in my hometown of ojai california
there's a tennis academy great tennis
academy right there and so i trained
with those guys when you have like five
or six coaches that your entire day is
devoted to learning something it's
really one of the things about this
profession i'm most grateful for and i
have a little brother
who um he was an all-american at
football and basketball he went and
played you know d1 college sports and he
kind of has been whooping my ass at
every i can whoop his ass in a fight but
he can
whoop me at every spin he's was killed
me a tennis woman for but now now i got
his number so yeah yeah yeah i'm i'm
excited about that
[Music]
oh that's so good
hey taste that vinegar
so you start on the new independent film
small engine repair a passion project of
you and director john polono which
started off as a small play in a tiny
theater of 40 people in los angeles what
is it that you find sacred or most
exciting about late night theater
productions like what was special to you
about the 10 30 pm show at the rogue
machine theater oh man that's a that's a
great question i i um
it's so um you know theater is uh it's
it's there's nowhere to hide you know
it's it's uh you get this uh this period
of time where it's just rehearsal where
you can just go and you can fall flat on
your face and you can push each other
and scare each other and and challenge
each other
that play started in the most humble way
and what's really beautiful about that
play in particular is a lot of my
buddies who are who are cops and
firefighters and and uh you know pro
fighters they were coming with sort of
the la theater audience and it was it
was um this opportunity everybody kind
of dug it in their own way and it was a
real sort of melding of of folks and we
knew we were kind of onto something
special and
yeah it was it was it was a beautiful
time in my life and and meeting john uh
you know he's he's one of my best
friends i'm just i'm super grateful for
it what role did the venue cafe lena in
saratoga springs new york
as a venue and building your confidence
as an actor how do you know about cafe
lena man
holy moly guacamole dude i cannot so uh
cafe lena is everything man that's my
heart man so cafe lena it's the first
coffee shop in upstate new york bob
dylan played had a teeny little black
box theater uh in the back and um you
know my first theater company is run by
uh this beautiful uh artist named josh
chambers we just lost him a a couple
months ago he was one of these guys that
i just he like burned too bright for
this world man uh real genius and and i
started you know doing these plays
in the black box of cafe lena uh you
know where we'd have sometimes more
people on stage than in the audience and
um
doing the most outlandish insane
experimental theater cafelina what a
sacred special spot man and above a
place called hatties which is one of the
best fried chicken restaurants in the
world and i could never afford it when i
was an actor there but uh i would love
smelling it you know what i mean yeah
just smelling that fried chicken man
[Music]
hmm
that's great
i would definitely i would definitely
use uh any of these so far i would love
to use these so far we'll see if i will
see if that goes
the punisher it features some of the
most brutal extraordinary fight scenes
ever on tv what are the hallmarks of a
good action sequence to you like from an
actor's perspective what separates a
good fight scene from a mediocre one i
really want to be with the characters i
really i i don't want it to be one note
i want to see when
they feel uh when there's fear i i i
love that uh when they feel like maybe
someone's getting the better hand
desperation um i think there's there's
potential for like real comedy um but
but i think like at the end of the day
what everybody is really craving in
those scenes is that you buy it that
that you buy it so it's the physicality
of of both delivering and selling the
blows or if you're playing somebody who
doesn't have those kinds of skills you
just got to play the emotionality of it
you got to kind of meld all those things
together and there's nothing i like
better than dancing with the stunt guys
when you get a group of guys that trust
you and that you trust you can take it
to a higher and higher level and turn it
up and it's it's uh i i love it man i
love it i'm so grateful to be kind of
welcomed into that community and my
friends in that community i i really
care about
[Music]
sweet huh
that's good do you eat the whole wing
i kind of mirror the guest you know so i
don't want to be like you know if i
guess i'm just taking a bite i don't
want to just be like cleaning wings i
don't want it to be like i'm showing off
on my show or something yeah but you're
you're the champ and i mean i do think
like i i dug out with matt you know he
was like eating the whole time like he
was really doing him yeah like i did
promise dom like i was not gonna take
baby boy but it's like i'm i'm really
gonna try to get it i know it's easy to
say on this half of the tray yeah i mean
i'm not trying to be you know cocky or
nothing but i'm i'm gonna try to eat you
know what i mean then i'm i'm right with
you then i'm right with you
so elizabeth olsen who we had on the
show last season likewise went to the
moscow art theater school and i was
really fascinated to learn about her
time there in particular getting a crash
course in fitz morris work thinking back
on that time what's an acting exercise
that you remember being an enlightening
eye-opening experience for an actor and
can you give me another one that was
just plain bizarre a cool exercise that
i always think about
you know they're constantly training
your your attention and your
concentration right so one thing that
they would do is they would give you a
newspaper right completely mundane
article
and you would have to read the first
paragraph of that article and you would
just sit in front of the class reading
it and while that was happening
people would ask you questions
what'd you have for breakfast today
somebody else said what color are your
socks
and you would have to answer each one of
those questions while you were reading
the the article at the same time
excuse me i'm good
uh
so good uh uh um
while you're answering those questions
and reading the article the teacher
would snap cough and clap
when it was over
everyone in the class he would just
point at people at random and you
you would have to say
how many times did i clap how many times
did i cough
who asked you this question what was the
answer and everyone had to know those
answers and then you would have to
recite the
the monologue the russian theater is
really all about ensemble building about
how do we strengthen this team how do we
all work together and the movies and the
projects that i've been in that i love
and that i think have been successful
have all been celebrations of that i
will say i took a clowning class
and
that first exercise was to come in and
make everyone laugh but you couldn't use
any words
and uh
everybody was failing miserably nobody
could do it so i put on my girlfriend's
sweatpants she had these like tight-ass
gray sweatpants i got in front of the
class you couldn't use any words you had
to make everybody laugh and you had two
minutes it was just people failed
miserably so i stood there and i started
like acting like i had to go to the
bathroom really bad i was like you know
i got and then i just like pissed myself
in front of the class you know what i
mean and everybody did laugh
you know but like why the [ __ ] did i you
know then i had to sit there with like
you know it was totally so that i think
it wasn't a bad exercise but i handled
it in a stupid way
[Music]
scorpion peppers huh where's this from
it's uh it's from pennsylvania wow
a little bit of a step up
yeah i can see that
all right john we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
graham where we do a deep dive on our
guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more contact so we'll
pull up the picture over here on the
monitor cool you just tell us the bigger
story yes sir
and then i know that you're passionate
about shutting down fighting kennels and
rescuing pitbulls like bam bam over here
yeah a little bit do you have any words
of wisdom for people who may have
rescued during the pandemic but don't
really know what they're doing
listen uh
look i think like the pitbull like the
breed specific legislation is uh
completely bonkers i think you know the
breed of your dog
does not make that dog any more or less
likely to be aggressive what comes hand
in hand with is you do have a
responsibility to train your dog my dogs
are on set with me they come with me
everywhere i don't need leashes or
collars my dogs don't scare people
they're great around kids they're
upstanding members of the community
there's nothing like going to a dog park
and seeing a dog that's fighting other
dogs and then the human being is like
holding that dog after the fight
petting it and saying don't do that
that's a really really but like what do
you think that dog is you know you're
you're telling that dog to go do it
again you got to be clear with the
animals so um that's that's kind of the
advice that that i would give and good
advice all right up next for an active
what was the most challenging thing
about shooting for eight months in the
close quarters of a sherman tank for
fury i love those guys man so look when
you first get in a 75 year old sherman
tank you know they say there's more
things that can kill you inside the tank
and outside of the tank you know the
turret moves people you know in training
you know horrible accidents happen all
the time
and you know when you get in there with
five guys there's
you know i know what each one of the i
know every smell that any one of those
guys is capable of like anything brad
pitt can do i know exactly what you
understand and so you know by the end of
that movie none of us would leave the
tank when it was over they say there's
no bond like a tank unit and that's
really how i feel about those guys you
know it's such a blessing to be able to
portray these things but do it under the
umbrella of safety and and then then
it's our job to sort of push it and make
it as as kind of dangerous as as
possible under that umbrella and i think
you just leave with unbelievable and
deep reverence for for for the guys that
that do it for real that's that's that's
how i am but yeah that's that's just a
typical that's that's just a typical day
in the mud there yeah
ghost peppers huh yeah yeah dude all
right stuff all right let's go
when i said that i realized there's a
little bit of cockiness and arrogance i
want to take that back you don't have to
edit it but i'm self-evident editing i'm
not being cocky or area not me because i
am like i'm really into the wings you
know man but i know it's about to get
real you're doing great though you're
doing great um
amazing
so you played tony soprano's father
johnny boy in the new prequel to the
sopranos the many saints of newark an
endless ink has been spilled about how
tony soprano helped usher in a whole new
era of masculinity on tv
and i liked a quote of yours i heard
when you said the least manly thing is
to be the loudest voice in the room
what's your relationship with the tough
guy characters that you play on camera
i just think that there's this thing
that's going on right now
uh just kind of um you know it's
everywhere it's it's in our politics
it's in our entertainment it's in it's
in how it's in our media where sort of
the rigidity and and and um unbending
sort of uh
uh just just inability to move off of
your opinion um that is being confused
with sort of patriotism and strength and
masculinity to say it's my way or the
highway where i think that for me that's
the most un-american thing in the world
and and i think um as far as being
you know a man i think you need to be
able to talk to anybody you need to be
confident enough in yourself um that you
know that you can make a mistake that
you can learn from everyone that you
should approach and engage in dialogue
with people that think completely
differently than you um the people that
i really respect and admire in my life
all have that i think people who
actually walk the walk that don't just
talk about it they all kind of live by
that code that you're constantly trying
to get better you're constantly trying
to grow it's not about implementing my
will on you and i think that
you know with this kind of masculinity
thing it's just i feel like it's sort of
been bastardized in this way that again
it's about the bombast it's about
looking tough and talk but you know
having empathy for people having
compassion for people helping people
being somebody uh wanting to be the kind
of person that will be there for someone
in need that what that's what i think
you know being being a dad's about being
a man's about and i certainly that's how
i'm trying to raise my my boys and um to
have an open heart uh towards everyone
[Music]
there's chocolate not yeah but holy [ __ ]
not the kind i think you may be like
hoping for [ __ ] you don't get chocolate
pepper
holy [ __ ] dude
[Music]
yeah man i'm gonna eat this whole
[ __ ] thing
doing what i said i do
holy moly
i understand that in ford vs ferrari
director james mangold kind of shied
away from green screen and embraced
classic hollywood filmmaking techniques
when you think about the creative ways
that he was able to capture the chaos of
car racing yeah what sorts of things
stand out
across the board look he's a genius you
know he's he's he's a he's a national
treasure you know and and i think what
really um was this uh homage to to kind
of classic filmmaking
for exactly what you said i think it's
more than just sort of the lack of
special effects and and and
what that does to have real race cars
screaming by
the actors
even if you never see the race cars the
sound of it the energy the palpability
of that informs all the performances
they're all really there and you can
feel them and i've been so blessed uh to
to to work holy [ __ ] that's hot you know
i've been so blessed maybe i gotta make
my answer shorter holy [ __ ] bro
and then martin scorsese is a director
who embraces improvisation i'm curious
how you think wolf of wall street might
have benefited from that approach i mean
it's the mountaintop you know it's never
there's no one better never will be uh
you know that process i learned more
even with that sort of limited role my
whole acting style kind of changed off
of that um no two takes were alike
everyone on that set everybody who steps
foot on that set you know is literally
the best in the world at what they do
there's such reverence there's such um
solitude and solidarity on those sets
a lot of times people talk about that
sell me this pen scene and i use it as a
really good example of the way that
marty kind of works
when leo was walking the set that day
uh you know his security was a new york
city detective and he said that he had
had a job interview with the real jordan
belfort and leo said really just walk
into set that day that we were shooting
that scene he said what was the
interview and he said he handed me a pen
said sell me that pen so leo just he
didn't tell anybody he just threw that
into that scene and then everything was
sort of reactive off of that
it just made it that it was electric and
you never knew it was going to happen
next
it changed the way i worked on
everything did they throw you a death
day party during your time on the
walking dead or is that a tradition that
started after you'd left no no it was
right no it was uh there's a place um
i forget the name of the there's a
there's a soul food
restaurant in atlanta that i remember
the waitress the first time we went
there she said this is going to make you
uncomfortably full and and so that's
where we always would do our death
dinners we started with the very first
one with amy and uh that group all those
guys from the originals um they're
they're they're family to me and i'm i'm
so i'm so grateful i got to be on that
show it it it it helped me in so many
ways
well speaking of eating until you're on
this next one is the bomb beyond
insanity yeah
[ __ ]
i mean what is that beyond and say so
like somebody reads that and they're
like oh yeah like uh yeah you go to
insanity then you gotta go beyond you
gotta go beyond bro
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
dom i want you to see what i'm doing
mother
[Music]
what's going on if you're gonna be a
bear be a grizzly you gotta be a grizzly
huh [ __ ] i mean that doesn't
even
[ __ ] there's two more
hmm i can't believe you can get
well yeah
and it kind of just grows on this one
kind of just grows
oh yeah
oh mother ever yeah
so in addition to training overseas i
know you're talking bro how are you you
just keep you just keep rolling okay
okay let's go i know that you also
played catcher on a pro baseball team
yeah russia yeah can you pull back the
curtain i hate it too fast what a mound
visit with john bernthal was like like
what would you say to a pitcher having
trouble spotting his fastball
you know i i love that position you you
know you're the fuel general
you know there's psychology that you're
constantly playing with the batter
and with the pitcher i'm gonna go into
the milk bro yeah me too me too i
already beat you there
that's beyond insanity
i got intense sometimes
as a catcher brother
that's all i got to say about that
what's the most intense high school
football game you remember playing in
during your undefeated season [ __ ]
with the sid well friendship
those guys are my best friends in the
world
dougie thornell greg zumas
we were undefeated man we grew up
playing together you know
wow bro
dude i can't believe there's two more
as an actor who frequents the petromali
boxing gym what do you think you know
dude what do you think is the greatest
boxing movie of all time
oh uh raging bull
raging bull you get right inside there
with it and and the character piece um
it's a hard sport to get right
not too many people
like what we're talking about with
tennis
yo
what we were talking about with tennis
there's not that many people who
actually have gotten in there but they
are unbelievably meticulous and there's
movies i think a lot of people consider
great that are full of boxing flaws it's
a tough one for me there's like it seems
like there's a million boxing movies
about white fighters it's not a white
sport and that's always been sort of a
source of contention with in the boxing
world um
but uh yeah i i think raging bull for me
is is the best
[Music]
i'm catching a little bit of a head okay
yeah yeah just catch a little bit of a
head buzz i think off that last one it's
weird man i'm so [ __ ] nervous that
he's next to but i'm also
i'm curious how we could get
[ __ ] stronger am i allowed to curse
go ahead let it fly let it fly
bro i've never seen you struggle dude
like this i like how you came up in your
you're like i come here with humility i
come in here yeah and you know me doing
been around the block so many times
maybe sometimes i take this for granted
but i think that first one reminded me
we're playing a dangerous it's not yeah
this is not this is not for
uh babies
all right so this is gonna do one like
circle yeah yeah whoa
hit a lap head oh my lordy all right
come on let's go let's go so this is
hellfire's cranked come on he'll fight
dude look at this mother look at him
look at him look at him
i mean look at i'm literally going to
have nightmares of this dude on here
what says eat me
reaper sauce
let's get it dude let's get it
i'm just doing one bite okay i'm good
just go one bite let's just call it one
let's just call that one
should we do two yeah okay let's do two
do you like to swallow quick
that was traditionally what i did
because i got to choke it down to get
the question yeah yeah but then after
that first one now quick i think it's a
mistake maybe i should slow it down it's
[ __ ] stupid man i'm sorry i'm cursing
so much sloane's gonna choke me out whoa
all right come on so you're a film buff
who counts true romance good fellas
silence of the lambs amongst your
favorite but you also speak very highly
of a little-known movie called dc caps
oh mr t yeah why do you refer to that
film as you call it the only honest dc
movie that's ever been made dc's never
portrayed the real dc is like never
portrayed in movies you know
dc growing up there it's very much a
studying hypocrisy
you know you've got like the federal
government there and it's all pristine
and it's uh you know patrolled by the
capitol police and the secret service
and then you know historically then you
go a couple blocks either way and it's a
very very different city and there's so
much vibrance and culture and vitality
to that city it's got its own
vernacular its own music i don't know if
you've ever heard go go music yeah hell
yeah but like [ __ ] it's so good where'd
you grow up chicago
um what's crazy about
[Music]
dc cab showed the real dc i love that
movie you know i mean i just love that
movie yeah well if nothing else we got a
shout out for dc cab today all right
john bernthal
[Music]
let's do this [ __ ] bro
i'm trying to watch you dude
oh my god
i'm going to run wipe off yeah
and then what you just you you you start
with the bite that you just you got it
good luck brother i appreciate it thank
you for having me man thanks so much for
coming dude seriously holy [ __ ]
cheers jon yeah respect bro
come on
come the [ __ ] on who would do that
you go over there come on let's go let's
go let's [ __ ] get it all right
i love it i love it you can't talk about
dc and then not do that the hell yeah
yeah i mean i know that's you that's how
[ __ ] genius he is dude
for dc
okay john bernthal long last we've
reached the conclusion of our noticing
journey yeah if we've learned anything
along the way it's that your path
through acting has likewise been a
roller coaster from russia to the states
to waking up at 5 00 a.m and driving to
actors equity for open auditions in a
ruthless jeep
for someone whose path to the silver
screen
wasn't the easiest what do you think is
the most important trait an aspiring
actor must have in order to grind and
make what make the way through the
unknown it's pretty
simple man i i think the mistake that so
many people make and i think you can do
this in professions across the board
to constantly worry about connections
getting in the right room you know
knowing the right people uh uh you put
all this time and effort as actors
having the right headshots you know
reaching out to people that you know
that might be in the industry it's not
about getting in the right rooms it's
just not it's about what you do when you
get in there
you have to love what you do and you
have to work at it like crazy because
you love it and so double down on that
and uh
give it everything you have man and and
uh and never ever ever ever ever give up
wise words to live by from john bernthal
and look at you my man taking on the
wings of death we did it and living to
tell the tale and now john bernthal
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life
many saints in newark that uh that comes
to theaters and hbo max
uh oh man
i'm sure this is exactly what they want
you know i mean maybe i'll puke one
while i'm delivering this
it's coming on october 1st king
richard's coming out i'm super proud of
it please go see small engine repair
it's it's a labor of love i guarantee
it'll make you
laugh it it might offend you it will
push you will challenge you um but
just uh be good be good to each other
just be good to each other that's that's
really what i want to say let's be good
to each other thank you for having me
man i have so much respect for you man
this was awesome thank you john what a
ride that was awesome
holy moly man yeah i actually think the
the hellfire was
it was the worst really you did not well
you know everybody always says to bomb
but i think that what happens is people
get shocked by de bomb they kind of like
don't see that next one coming but yeah
this one this season hit that's all it's
just like strength to strength the
strength
yeah yeah yeah and we were taking those
big bites so we'd like get you on the
yeah
wow just gotta do one more glass of
water
[Applause]
hey what's going on everybody this is
sean evans i just wanted to say thank
you so much for watching today's episode
and as you know every season it's out
with the old and in with the new hot
sauce lineup and i know you've been
watching this episode and wondering to
yourself i wonder if i would cry like
that would i sweat would i scream well
now you can find out because the hot
ones 10 pack is available at
heatness.com that's heatness.com to get
your hands on the hot ones 10 pack
remember with the last ab you don't have
to if you don't want to keep milk on
hand keep ice cream at the ready you can
do this
[Music]
you